hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where as has been requested many
times now
in this video i'm going to talk about
some of the work from the lab of irena
and michael convoy
in particular focusing on their more
recent work looking at neutral blood
exchange
so to break this video down we'll begin
by talking about where all this research
started
then talk specifically about mutual
blood exchange and about the different
components that can be found
in the blood as well as taking a look at
the results from these two
studies that came out in 2020 one
looking specifically at how
this blood exchange rejuvenated the
three different germ layers in mice
and then a second follow-up paper that
focused a bit more specifically at the
rejuvenation process on neurogenesis
so the best place to begin is probably
where i ended a recent video discussing
is aging contagious because at the end
of this video
once i'd argued my case for why agent
could be considered contagious
i introduced you to the landmark 2005
paper
rejuvenation of aged progenitor cells by
exposure to a young systemic environment
so in this paper conducted by the
convoys what they did was perform
something known as heterochronic
parabaosis
which is why you share a circulatory
system and they did this between young
and old mice
and what they saw is that by exposing
the old mice to factors present in the
young serum
it showed signs of rejuvenation in their
muscle and liver tissue
and so what this early work led to was
the idea that there's something in the
blood
and so well what is in bloods well there
are many different components that make
up what you refer to as blood
most obvious are your blood cells
including your red blood cells that
carry
oxygen around your body in addition to
white blood cells and platelets
but in addition there's the plasma the
soluble fraction of blood
and it contains water ions proteins
nutrients
wastes and gases and amongst this also
includes hormones and other signaling
molecules
these enable cells to communicate with
each other whereby one organ can release
a signal
a hormone directly into the blood and it
can be carried about all over the body
to be recognized by specific target
cells
so it's notable to mention then that one
of the hallmarks of aging
is altered cellular communication and
further supporting the theory that
there's something going on
in the blood in terms of aging processes
it's a study that came out in 2019
which effectively mapped the human
plasma proteum across lifespan and
identified different sets of proteins
that have different trajectories across
aging for example either they increased
or decreased
and the interesting thing was that it
wasn't necessarily a linear process
but it was dynamic and non-linear and so
they referred to these changes
as undulating proteomic changes and i
have a full video describing this paper
which only roughly 140 of you have
watched
10 of those fees are probably me anyway
so i definitely recommend you checking
that one out after this video
but anyway back to the convoys after the
early work on heterochronic parabiosis
they were trying to identify what it was
about the changes in the blood
that were causing these rejuvenative
effects was it something that was in the
young blood
or was it just the fact that the old
blood was getting rid of some of the
accumulation of these proteins
so a best way of thinking of it is a
dilution of factors in the old blood
by mixing it with the young bloods and
this would be definitely desirable
given the controversy with using young
blood especially in terms of translation
to human therapies
and it'd probably be more cost effective
and safer if alternative methods were
identified
so what they decided to do was
investigate whether or not the same
rejuvenative effects could be seen in
the old mice if they simply just diluted
the blood
and the way that they do this is through
a process that they refer to
as neutral blood exchange so effectively
what they do
is they take out the blood from the old
mice not all of it obviously
and they spin it down and separate it
out into these different layers of the
bloods which i described earlier
and so they remove the plasma and what
they can do is replace
this platelet-rich plasma to this top
section with saline solution
supplemented with albumin and so the
reason that albumin is added is because
it's the main protein found in
blood plasma in mice and humans making
up around 50
of human plasma proteins and in addition
to this it helps to regulate the osmotic
potential
so that when that plasma is reintroduced
into the blood system
it doesn't disrupt the volume of the
blood content and so the way that this
neutral blood exchange is performed in
these studies
is by replacing 50 of this platelet-rich
plasma
and then returning it isochronically to
the animal along with red and white
blood cells
so when this first study that came out
in may last year
they performed this neutral blood
exchange which i'll probably refer to as
nbe from now on in both young and old
mice
and notably it was only done in male
mice which i'll actually come back to at
the end
and both the young and old mice
underwent one of these
nbes and so once this had happened they
wanted to assess whether or not there
was rejuvenation in the three germ
layers
and the three germ layers refers to the
three layers
of tissues that form in our body
originating from early development
so in this case they looked at neurons
which is your outer layer
they looked at the muscle tissue which
is your middle layer
and they also looked at the liver which
is your inner layer so the first thing
that they assessed was the repair of
injured muscle
in the mice and they did this by
assessing four independent
characterizations
for example as you can see in these
figures here the neutral blood exchange
in the
old mice so onve results in the
regenerative index more closely matching
what's seen in young mice compared to
old mice similarly
with the fibrotic index the other data
we're showing is how they also studied
how muscle progenitor cells
replicative potential altered when they
were treated with either samples from
human patients this time
that had undergone the fda approved
equivalent of
mbe which is therapeutic plasma exchange
and so here they took blood samples from
human samples aged between 65 to 70
years of age
collected either before or after a
therapeutic plasma exchange
and then they added these samples to
muscle progenitor cells so this time
obviously we're looking in vitro
and you can see here that on addition of
the blood that was
post the therapeutic plasma exchange
there's a much greater increase in the
levels of brdu which basically stains
for cells that are undergoing
replication
so going back to the mice that underwent
mbu they next looked at the liver
and they showed as you can see in this
figure here that the liver fibrosis
reduced
in old mice after a single procedure of
neutral blood exchange
so after examining both the liver and
muscle they also wanted to examine
whether or not the neutral blood
exchange had an impact on brain
hippocampal neurogenesis
and one of the reasons why they were
interested in looking at this is because
heterochronic parabiliosis
showed in this 2011 paper that it could
promote adult neurogenesis
in aging mice and so what you can see in
these figures here is that they stained
the dentate gyrus
for a marker of proliferation of cells
the dentate gyrus just being a region of
the hippocampus
and so you can see in the old mice that
had undergone this nve treatment there's
more of these thoughts
which effectively indicates that there
are more cells undergoing proliferation
indicative of neurogenesis and so one of
the proposed functions of the dentate
gyrus is in memory formation
and so in this later 2020 paper they
looked more closely at how this mpe
treatment could alter the memory of the
older mice
and as you can see in this figure here
the older mice to underwent
mbe performed similarly to young mice in
whisker discrimination
which assesses sensory processing and
also
novel object recognition where both
sensory and memory information is being
tested
and so i've only really touched upon
some of the phenotypic data that they
got in these studies
but what i think is more interesting is
to examine their results that try to
answer the question
as to how are these effects being
mediated what is it about this nbe
treatment
that could be causing these changes so
if we go back again to this first study
that came out last year
then we can see at the end of the study
that they performed a proteomic array
to assess the different proteins in the
mouth serum taken from the mice before
and
after the npe treatment and so the first
observation that you can make is that
the profile of these different proteins
and the old mbe mice has similarities to
a young mouse profile in comparison to
an old mouse control sample
but what i find most striking about
their data set is that in the samples
taken from the old mice that underwent
mbe
they see an increase in the level of
several proteins
suggesting that they've been upregulated
which may at first be counterintuitive
given the fact that you've removed some
of the plasma and just replaced it with
albumin
and so at the end of the study they
proposed a model to explain how the
dilution effect
of the mbe treatment can potentially be
resetting the circulatory proteome
and so okay this looks a little bit
scary so i'm going to redraw it out
myself and hopefully try and explain it
at the same time
emphasis on hopefully so in that model
they used the example of the trgf beta
family
and so tgf beta proteins have been shown
to increase systemically with age
and tgf beta is commonly associated with
upregulation of inflammatory signaling
in particular it's been shown previously
that tgf beta
could be acting to induce paracrine
induced senescence in neighboring cells
but interestingly tgf-beta proteins have
also been shown to act as autoinducers
so they can upregulate their own
expression so i'll refer to it from now
on as a
so if we now try and plot a graph of how
the levels of a
change over time then initially there'd
be a decrease in the relative abundance
of a due to the fact that it's going to
be diluted by the nve
and so proteins like tgf beta have other
proteins that they can activate through
their signaling pathways
and other proteins that they can inhibit
and these have their own feedback
mechanisms
that can result in impinging the
activity of
a tgf beta and so this is where it gets
a little bit complicated
and why this should only be thought of
as the model because
in a real case situation it would just
be way more complicated and this
is definitely somewhat oversimplified
and just
hypothetical at the moment so in this
hypothetical situation
we have a which could be tgf beta
auto-inducing itself
activating something the authors call c
which inhibits a so we've got a bit of a
negative feedback system going on here
and then another example where a is
inhibiting
a difference factor b and so if we go
back to the graph
as i mentioned initially due to the
dilution we have a reduction in the
levels of a
and since a is activating c you also see
a reduction in the levels of c
albeit as a time delay to a at the same
time we will also now start to see an
increase in b
as i mentioned c is a negative regulator
of a
and so if c starts to decrease because
there's less activation from a
then that also means there's less
repression of a and so the levels of a
will start to come back a bit and then
as the levels come back a bit
it can activate c which then inhibits a
and then this is why you can get a bit
of an oscillatory pattern
and then at the same time we also have
oscillating levels
in b because b is getting inhibited by a
which is getting reduced but then going
up back up again and down and up and
down and up
and so basically b is the in first
pattern of a
and so depending on the protein in
question the time duration
of these different events will vary in
addition to the complexity of the
interactions
and so the only way that they'd really
be able to ever validate this model is
to be able to take
more time points after the npe has taken
place
but as they mentioned fitting the model
shown with experimental data on multiple
time points
after nve for multiple proteins and
multiple levels of regulation
so not just protein abundance but also
mrna and signaling intensities
is a focus of their long-term work and
so nbe
is just a version of therapeutic plasma
exchange which is already fda
approved and is routinely used in the
clinic so
it's possible that you've already had
therapeutic plasma exchange
and so along with their pre-clinical
data in their study
they've also done a pilot's longitudinal
study with samples from several old
individuals
showing the impact of therapeutic plasma
exchange and so
phase 2b and phase 3 clinical trials are
being actively developed
and so this method in general shifts the
paradigm from there being potential
dominant factors in
young plasma to instead showing that
dilution
could be sufficient if not potentially
better
to see beneficial effects now i think
there's a lot of work still to be done
in terms of a seeing what these
potential beneficial effects are
and then secondly to try and understand
why they're happening
but i can understand that based on their
data it does seem quite promising
at the moment and i also think it's
quite a clever idea
in addition to the fact that by having
such a such a dramatic dilution
it impacts so many different factors
which could explain why it's having
impacts on multiple different tissue
types however as i just said the fact
that it is impacting multiple factors
there could also be some potential
negative consequences for example the
blood is
used to carry a lot of hormonal signals
and they only did the my studies and
males
and so the molecular mechanisms and
consequences of doing this in female
mice
is well at least i don't think it's been
explored and so
that definitely would be something i'd
be interested in knowing more about
and more on from that there therefore
could be certain times of the day or
certain times of the month where it is
more effective or safer to do so
and other interesting questions to
answer would be how long do the effects
last
does it have an impact on health span
markers or biological age
or lifespan itself um so there's a lot
of unanswered questions i mean obviously
these things aren't necessarily cheap
to try and do experimentally but
probably suggest that before these are
done
more progemics and rna sequencing should
be done to really try and see
what the immediate impacts are in terms
of the changes in the protein
abundance so so a lot to explore with
this
but i do think given the fda approval of
therapeutic plasma exchange
this is something that yeah i suppose we
should be quite excited about
so with that i just want to quickly say
that the first paper if you want to know
more detail about it was covered in a
journal club
by lifespan extension advocacy
foundation so
go check that out if you're interested
but as always i hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
as always thanks for listening